[Music]
and e4
c5
d6 we're gonna play the night or
okay so bishop c4 and what's interesting
and this is surprising to me most people
are still playing relatively obscure
anti-sicilians our response to this and
we face this move many many times our
response to this should just be to
develop our pieces there is nothing
special that white black is supposed to
do against this
we just go knight f6
then we go
knight c6
yeah and i'm happy to play shroom it
goes without saying you get dibs on on
playing now very very important point
there is a trap here that people who
play this with white always rely on you
do not want to go bishop g4 and i'll
show this in depth after the game but
bishop g4 is a terrible move on account
of queen b3
four king the b7 pawn and the f7 pawn
whatever you do in this position do not
go bishop g4 there are two ways of
playing this properly
you can play it with
fiancado you can play g6 right or the
the line that i like is just to play e6
and bishop e7 very modest
very modest but very very solid we
basically immobilize this bishop
then we play bishop b7 we castle and
what you're often going to see in this
line white is often going to drop the
bishop back to b3 kind of like white
does in an italian or lopez and when
that happens we often want to play the
move b5
in order to expand on the queen side so
let's start by castling and completing
our king side development but our bishop
is also immobilized that's true but
we'll we'll deal with our bishop our
bishop will eventually find a nice
square okay now how should we continue
here there's many ways that we could
play this we could push d5 absolutely
could push d5
we could do something a little bit more
mod we could play a6 and b5 right
and you have to understand that in such
open-ended positions there's gonna be
like four or five different ways of
playing it and you shouldn't sit there
for an hour and you know try to
distinguish between two equivalent ideas
i like the move d5 because it's
ambitious and we're playing in the
center and we're grabbing more space
and i like
trying to punish such lines by playing
principled moves right there's just
something
macho about playing d5 in this position
we're not messing around and we're
showing our opponent that we're not
messing around he takes d5 i think is
inaccurate
obviously we're going well not obviously
we could take with an actually we could
very much take with the knight here i
like this move and then play b6 and
bishop b7 that's a setup i think is
really underrated knight takes d5 and
then b6 and bishop b7 the point is that
we preserve the potential contact on the
d3 pawn let me think about this for a
second you know what let's do it let's
see what happens if we play knight takes
d5 i know this is a very
counter-intuitive move very
counter-intuitive but
i can almost guarantee you that it's
going to work out in our favor he might
open up with d4 that's absolutely true
but if we plays d4 we still go b6
we still go b6
knight e4
okay b6
why b6 for two reasons we defend the
pawn on c5 and we prepare to develop our
light squared bishop to b7
okay but should be seven we develop our
bishop defending the knight
and i think that black is slightly
better here
our p look how nicely our pieces are all
positioned like every piece is in the
center
our pawns are all defending each other
like everything is so compact
and very often a blunder happens
immediately when in such a situation and
a blunder has happened immediately
knight g5 loses the game on the spot to
what move
we take the bishop thank you very much
and then we take the knight on g5 and
then we win that's all there is to it
that's all there is to it yeah that's
very disappointing from our 2000
opponent now there is the move queen h5
here i hope that some of you might
notice the possibility of queen h5 but
queen h5 is
is ineffective
why is it ineffective because of h6 and
we counter attack the knight on g5 and
defend against me made at the same time
okay goodbye yeah that's bad that that's
actually bad from all perspe like white
played the opening terribly
not terribly but like very in a very
lackluster manner
and then
followed up with shoddy play
yeah that was i'm sorry about that
if white continues and i have an idea
for the next game i'm gonna have to run
it by our vip here but my idea was
actually to do like a peace blunder at
this level
and and to see if i can actually bounce
back from a from a down a piece position
at a 2000 level which might lead to a
loss i'm not gonna deny that but that
could be really interesting to to really
it would really press me okay let's go
rook 88 get the rook into the game
that's gonna be fun we're gonna do that
next game i'm gonna have coffee
so we're gonna be fully fully equipped
okay now let's let's focus on proper
technique here because while this might
be boring to you
i still believe it is important to
to understand how to properly convert
such positions most of you do need work
on that front so let's not let's not
relax just yet
we need to have here a general idea of
what it is that we're aiming to do
basically two types of or three types of
moves when you're converting an
advantage there is moves that just
improve your position for example i
would consider the move h6 i would play
this move at some point not necessarily
now but at some point so there's general
improving moves
there are simplifying moves moves that
trade pieces and advance closer to the
ultimate goal of winning the game
and then there are moves that accomplish
some larger scale agenda like what are
we actually aiming to attack how are we
going to win this apart from simplifying
well
the most to me the most effective plan
here involves attacking the pawn on z3
piling up the pressure on that pawn
so let us begin doing that
and let's start doing that by playing
the move rook d7
now you might say why are we walking
into the spin well this pin is
completely innocuous but white has no
way of putting more pressure on the
knight on c6 he simply lacks the minor
pieces to do so
and we can also follow up by playing a6
and forcing this bishop out of b5
then we play b5 then we play rook d8
knight e5 and we pile up as much
pressure as possible on the pawn on d3
why did i not play rook d6 there is a
reason the reason is that i anticipated
that white's gonna double on the f-file
and i didn't want the f7 pawn to be
hanging in that situation
so this rook is going to accomplish both
a defensive task and an attacking task
does that make sense
okay so we can play b5 we can play rook
d8 it doesn't really matter what we do
first what we do second let's start by
doubling rooks
then we play b5
yeah rook g3 big deal right no problem
at all we move our queen back where do
we move it back well i wouldn't move it
back to e5 because that's the square we
want to reserve
for our knight instead let us drop the
queen back to e7 just you know all of
our pieces nicely positioned in the
center then we're going to play b5 and
our opponent is defending pretty
decently here but he's down a full piece
there's nothing that white can do here
just absolutely nothing
okay he wants me i see our opponent
recruited him because he wants me to get
distracted and take on d3 by accident
but we ain't gonna blunder checkmate
okay the this is gg but but like
we still want to be precise
you want to treat every position
as though it's a teachable moment and it
is okay so what should we do now well we
continue
following up on our plan with 95 putting
more pressure on d3
right methodical you you set yourself a
goal we want to attack d3 and then every
move advances that goal or advances one
of two other goals it either simplifies
or it improves your position on some
surface level way okay okay
so here i feel like a lot of you might
be tempted to go c4 that would be a
serious mistake because it would allow
white to play d4 and that would be the
exact opposite of what we want that
would give white this pawn chain
so
can we put more pressure on the d3 pawn
can we develop an idea that will enable
us to do that what piece can we use in
order to accomplish that wouldn't it be
great if we could use our light squared
bishop
well we can use our light squared bishop
we just need to put it on this diagonal
well we can't play bishop a6 but we can
play the move a5 and follow it up with
bishop a6 a classic idea
there it is and now we are going to win
the spawn
just methodical high quality play and if
we need to we can even recruit the queen
as well we simply have more pieces than
black does but you might say but why
does c4
how has the position changed as a result
of c4 well a huge massive hole has been
created on d4
in addition we have a tactic if we so
desire
if we so desire we have now the
positional approach would be to play
knight c6
and uh and knight e4 we could also stick
a rook on d4 but there is a cool tactic
that doesn't quite work bishop takes c4
some of you are seeing dc rook d2
there's a ridiculous resource queen h5
there counter-attacking the knight
i almost went for it
now if you wanted to apply that we could
probably play knight takes c4 but why
are we bothering with that why are we
bothering with any of that let's just go
let's just go knight c6 and knight e4
let's play this positionally right
we've traded in our advantage
and now we convert that advantage into
something else
now we are threatening bishop takes c4
we are threatening bishop takes c4 here
because now that the knight is no longer
on a vulnerable square we are
threatening to take on c4
queen e3 yep okay fair enough i think
that rather than playing knight d4 we
have a more direct approach toward
winning this game
and that is to play knight b4 right
attacking the bishop attacking the pawn
and once the bishop moves we can finally
start grabbing stuff
i have to say our opponent like he's
defended this as well as one could
possibly defend this like he hasn't made
it easy but there goes the pawn and once
that first pawn disappears the entire
position is going to collapse
yeah why i don't know why our opponent
didn't play like this before and now the
bishop on a6 has done its job what does
it mean for a piece to have done its job
well it means that it's no longer doing
anything on a6 it's biting on granite
so we have two options we can retreat
our knight back to e5 but we are not
worried about white taking twice on d3
because two pieces two pieces for a
queen a bishop and two pawns isn't even
close so what move am i proposing bishop
back to b7 putting pressure on the e4
pawn
notice that we're
flexible in the way that we approach the
position we had one plan
that plan yielded a
certain result
then we immediately transitioned to a
second plan occupying d4 then we pivoted
back to the first one attacking d3 again
and now we're pivoting back to a
different way of playing we're
retreating our pieces and preparing for
the decisive invasion
okay rook h3
does white have a threat
well you might say yes white has a
threat queen h6 but but don't rush right
is queen h6 actually a threat does it so
is it something we need to do something
about if you look more carefully you
will see that the answer is actually no
how can queen h6 be properly met yeah we
can just play f6
so the best thing to do here would be to
go 95 i wouldn't even go f5 but we could
go f5 but opening up the position here
is basically unnecessary f6 rook takes
f6 we play queen takes f6 and uh rook on
d7 remember all that time ago i put my
rook on d7 rather than d6
it's not because i knew that this would
happen it's just that the rook on the
seventh rank
generally defends important targets
on that very same seventh ring so the
rook also defends h7 if rook have six we
go queen f6 and the game is over what is
our next move going to be very likely
not knight g4 that's not necessary this
is not bothering us this is not
bothering us let it sit there
rook d1
uh second type of move we have a chance
at simplifying and eliminating the only
defender of white's king once we play
rook d1 the floodgates basically open
queen g7 is also possible you can smoke
that queen out of there if you so desire
okay
change of plans right
it's important when you're converting
not to just tell yourself okay i'm going
to play this move regardless of what y
does right you actually have to look at
what your opponent has done before you
decide on the move you play and if you
do that then you're often able to find
better moves this is a great example of
that here goes knight g4 winning the
push of the exchange on e3 and we're
going to be at rook up
and then we're going to play rook d1
bang
and here comes the rook put that in your
pipe and smoke it and there comes the
rook
take it
now let us activate our final piece the
queen comes out to d6 attacking h2 here
you should be able to convert this
without
much difficulty
and by the way one underrated uh
training tool
i can recommend for you
is uh you know if you're if you're a
beginner this is more for you know you
know beginner players but if you're
you know if you've screwed up a
completely winning position you can play
out certain positions against the
computer only chess and and chess.com
that's also possible so playing certain
positions out against the engine like
you can start with completely winning
positions just to make sure that you
know how to convert them
okay so rather than just trading queens
blindly there is a better move last
question to you guys in this game
can you find the most effective winning
word
winning move yeah check classic idea
paving the way for rook d2 and if the
queen blocks then we drop back and take
the bish punty too okay and white
resigns
so basically the one thing that you want
to avoid in this line if you're a
sicilian player
is the move bishop g4 this is a common
and very very well-known mistake
and it is a mistake because of queen b3
attacking f7 attacking b7 this is a
problem because you cannot defend both
at the same time
for example e6 queen takes b7 and you
can actually lose really really quickly
here like if you go knight a5 you
already lose this should be five check
knight d7 bishop takes d7
and uh you're busted because you can't
take back the
loss so
just don't don't forget about that and
that's why we played e6 we keep the
bishop on c8
okay so we developed the bishop to e7
we castle yeah white is developed white
played this in a very lackluster manner
and so we play principally with d5 some
other plans in this position involve
for example playing a6 and b5
or playing b6 and bishop b7 that's also
totally fine
uh but we decided to play in a
principled fashion
now probably
white is best advice is to drop the
bishop back to b3 i don't know why our
opponent was so like
i don't know so lackluster in the
opening d d is just really giving up the
center like that it's weird
yeah so we decided to take with the
knight
this structure in particular with the
pawns on d3 and c3
it occurs sometimes in the king's indian
attack and it's never particularly good
for the side of the pawns like that
it's just not not all that great
and i could probably find for you some
uh real life over the board games with
this exact pawn structure where
the side that plays against them wins in
a pretty straightforward fashion let me
see what i can do and this also happens
often in the french if you think about
it so here's an example that i just
found
okay so some some random game this this
occurred out of a french
this occurred out of a french this queen
e2 line that perhaps some of you have
seen before
black puts together this botvanic setup
with bishop on g7 and knight on e7
and you can probably see where this is
going
black plays d5 e takes d5 and here i
think again most people would probably
play ed automatically but not andrew big
knight takes d5
and he he actually
wins this in very simple fashion he
drops the knight back to e7 nice move
attacking d3 and here white makes a big
mistake white plays the
highly anti-positional move c4 creating
a gaping hole on the d4 square which
andrew
dutifully
exploits he gets his knight to d4
he establishes a rook on d4 he doubles
on the d file
and all that remains in this position
is to get rid of the bishop on d5 which
he does by dropping his bishop back to
b7
and after the trades he wins the pawn on
d5 and ends up winning the game so
not the best example but you can see
that these structures actually do occur
in real life and
you know they're generally good for
black
um and if you were to be really
dedicated
you know what one thing you could do is
you could sort of have a notebook where
you collect typical pawn structures and
how to play against them
so doretsky in his old books actually
advocates printing and cutting out
diagrams
of like key positions from your games
that you can then review that's a little
bit much and you can do that on the
computer but if you really want to do
this properly you can have a notebook
like that
so hopefully it makes sense why to take
the knight with the with the knight on
the pawn so we go b6
then we go bishop b7
then we're putting openings and binders
then white blunder the piece
unfortunately this game was cut short by
the move knight g5
white is already worse i mean everything
is in perfect places
we want to go queen c7 and rook a d8 and
put pressure on the pawn black is just
slightly better here so
it's sad that our opponent blundered a
piece like this but uh
obviously
nothing that we can do about it we take
the free piece
then we create a general plan basically
doubling on the d file
getting the knights e5 and then
activating the bishop via a6
forcing c4 moving the knight back around
either to d4 or to b4 as happened in the
game
yeah even without the bishop blunder it
sucks because we could play h6 now one
very quick point
a lot of you discovered this tactic
bishop takes c4 and rook d2 you want to
be very careful when you're up a lot of
material you want to be careful about
making overly fancy moves because it
sometimes backfires
and here it would backfire on account of
queen h5 attacking the knight on e5
using the pin
and we lose our extra piece we're still
winning here but i mean the game
continues
now you could probably play knight take
c4 to circumvent that
but here why it has like this move
and then you have to go here
and i didn't want to calculate this that
all of this over one pawn
is not is not worth it even though this
is a cool move and probably it does work
you could play knight take c4
also i was a little bit reticent about
just giving up this incredibly beautiful
knight so instead we decided on knight
c6 but now we switch gears again and now
we saw an opportunity to win the d3 pawn
for free and we do it and it's over and
that's the rest of the game would f6
instead of g6 have worked
um
f6
would work but it weakens the e6 square
so if i were to really nitpick if i were
to really nitpick we will do the
blunderpiece game
if i were to really nitpick i would say
that i wouldn't want to weaken the e6
square
so g6 is a better way to do it
in the meantime
maybe as i drink coffee i can
answer some general questions and then
we can move on to the peace blender game
i mean i don't have anything
particularly
enlightening to say about the magnus
situation
situations like these happen
i don't think it changes anything i
think if anything the one good thing
that might come of it if magnus
if magnus
develops a desire like five years later
to play again he'll have to play the
candidates tournament if magnus plays
the candidates tournament imagine how
many people are going to watch that so
maybe magnus just wants to see
you know what will happen in the chess
world
uh what what will happen in the chess
world and you know he just wants to
chill but for magnus you know like he
has reached a point where he is so
dominant over the chess world and has
been for such a long time that's my
bottom line point that like he
you know he has nothing left to prove
and he's only 31 years old so
you know five years could pass and
magnus could say hey you know what
ali reza farouz is the world champion i
want to get back in the saddle and he
wins the candidates and then challenges
foruja so
he might come back this isn't the end of
his career i think he made it very clear
that this is not pre-retirement chess
he's still
like he's still going to play he still
wants 2 900. he might still play the
world championship match i just feel
like he
just got bored i think that's all there
is to it i don't think there's anything
deeper that some people are not seeing
anyways what if fidei won't allow him no
fiji will allow him to play the
candidates come on if he won't allow
magnus to play the candidates there will
be a large-scale mutiny nobody will play
the candidates after i see car i don't
think hikaru said that he literally
doesn't care about finishing second
of course hikaru i can guarantee you is
very very in a lot of pain from it
because he's going to be
regretting tremendously the decisions he
made against deng but
okay obviously hikaru cares
and he would be a psychopath for not
caring of course he cares of course it
stings him i'm sure
i'm sure he feels terrible about not
drawing ding
and i could see it in the closing
ceremony like i you know
i could see that it was getting to him
but if it weren't getting to him
uh then
you should be very concerned like if
you're a hikaru fan and he doesn't care
about succeeding and trying to become
world champion and something's wrong
yeah i think that's possible that if he
came second then magnus would actually
play nepo but there's no way to tell and
there's no reason to speculate
maybe magnus will come on to leech us
then i'll challenge him let me actually
check that
wouldn't that be amazing if i had a
match against magnus right now
he is not online unfortunately
but that would be amazing he's not
online
okay
[Music]